[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es eine
richtig leckeres dessert wir machen
einen no bnq kochen bzw erdbeer
schnitten mit frischen erdbeeren ich
deutsche so ein bisschen die
erdbeersaison ein dieses jahr könnt ihr
euch wieder auf ganz ganz viele leckere
rezepte freuen ich benutze jetzt
zuallererst wir starten mit dem boden
quasi und aber auch mit dem deckel welt
gleich sehen warum ich das sage ich habe
mir diese mister krimi kekse vom kauf
nahm das ist ein rodeo lieber wenn dich
heute und da müssen wir einmal die creme
rausnehmen wenn wir brauchen hier erst
mal nur den keks die gebe ich jetzt die
schüssel gebe ich direkt in mein mixa
wenn das wird anschließend fein und nix
dann werde ich butter schmelzen und mit
dazu geben das mache ich eine mikrowelle
bei geringerer zahl
[Musik]
die füllung von den keksen brauchen wir
in diesem rezept nicht aber schmeißt es
auf keinen fall weg daraus kann man noch
so viele andere sachen machen oder zum
beispiel in euer nächstes torten projekt
reingeben hält auch ein paar tage im
kühlschrank so und jetzt nehme ich mir
hier doch die schüssel ich habe euch
natürlich wie immer alle ganz gern
mengenangaben in die infobox so und
jetzt gebe ich hier butter mit rein für
den boden und das andere geben wir zur
seite das brauchen wir nämlich nachher
[Musik]
man bekam habe ich auf kleinste stufe
eingestellt und auf ein serviertablett
gegeben ihr könnt auch gerne ein
backpapier untendrunter legen ich habe
zufällig ein weißes da gehabt zwar nicht
ein bisschen schicker und dann einfach
den keks boden reingehen und flach an
drücken wir machen nichts weiter mit
unserer zwischenschicht dafür habe ich
hier frische erdbeeren außerhalb der
saison könnt ihr auch tiefgekühlte
verwenden die habe ich schon gewaschen
und das werde ich jetzt einfach pürieren
und danach passieren durch ein sieb weil
ich einfach diese diese groben kerpen
ist auch noch gerne auf jeden fall
möchte ich die nicht so gern haben und
deswegen passiert ich das gleich noch
mal wenn die schwierigkeiten habe das zu
kurieren könnt ihr noch ein maximal zwei
esslöffel wasser dazugeben aber
grundsätzlich erhalten die schon genug
wasser daher sollte das kein problem
sein
[Musik]
ich habe übrigens direkt in den topf
gegeben weil wir das gleich sowieso
alles in einen topf aufkochen wenn und
es sind samen und natürlich keine kerne
die samen sind jetzt hier die
wunderschön aufgefangen die bäume an der
stelle nicht das kommt weg und jetzt
kommt alles andere rein bis auf die
butter das heißt wir haben natürlich
milch für unseren pudding es wird halt
pohl in krems dann kommt ein bisschen
sahne dazu so kann natürlich für die
süße und ein bisschen speisestärke für
die bindung und dann wird das ganze
unter ständigem rühren einmal aufgekocht
und dann liegt es auch schon 1
[Musik]
nach dem einlegen dann einfach nur noch
die butter dazugeben hat habe ich
natürlich schon
ausgehalten ausgeschaltet in dem moment
und die butter schmilzt quasi in der
rest hitze jetzt habe ich mir gedacht
das auge isst mit es ist schon ein
superschönes pastellige rosa aber da
geht noch was also ein mini ist ein mini
bisschen von der bordeaux und
lebensmittelfarbe und dann gucken wir
mal dass ich die farbe da ein bisschen
verändert und dann ganz ganz wichtig
noch vanille exakter zu geben vanille
und erdbeer menschen einfach sehr gut
[Musik]
so jetzt finde ich die farbe auch
wunderschön und jetzt kommt das ganze
noch warm einfach auf den boden und dann
gehen wir auch direkt die übrig
gelassenen kicks krümmel darüber dass es
gar kein problem das der pudding noch
warm ist also im gegenteil das soll
sogar so einfach nur schön glatt
verstreichen und dann die keks krümeln
obendrüber legen und ganz ganz wichtig
ist dass ihr das dann wirklich
mindestens sechs stunden lang kühlen am
allerbesten über nacht also mach das
auch gerne am vortag schon oder macht es
morgens für abends das ist ja ganz
entspannt dass man solche sachen
wirklich am vortag vorbereiten kann dann
hat man für den nächsten tag ein dessert
[Musik]
ich mache so dass ich das ganze nach der
kür zeit mit einem backform löser lösen
bzw dem bug raum entferne in quadrate
bzw 1 rechtecke schneiden und dann könnt
ihr gerne noch mit frischen erdbeeren
dekorieren die ihr dann einfach so ein
bisschen auffächert und das ganze ist
einfach nur ein sehr leichtes dessert
ein leckeres sehr sehr erfrischend und
liegt halt auch nicht schwer im magen
also macht es unbedingt nach abonniert
main kanal wenn ihr das nicht schon
längst getan habt einfach passt ihr
meine rezepte auch nicht mehr und dann
freue ich mich wenn ihr beim nächsten
rezept dabei seid teams wo ich sogar
sagen den habe ich mir eindeutig für den
toner blockhaus probieren wir mal
schmeckt sehr interessant und sehr
lecker
[Musik]